Remember that our program is mostly
funded by members who sign up at
join Pacman dot com, who can be a member.
You can be a member. Grab a membership at
join Pacman dot com. So there's been this trending
story that was really fueled by Donald Trump that
after last week's second and final presidential
debate, millions and millions of people started
Googling, How can I change my vote if I've
already sent in my vote? If I voted early,
can I change my vote? The idea being people saw
Trump's powerful alpha performance on Thursday
and said, oh, no, I voted for Biden, but I
must change my vote to Trump. Can I do it?
Unfortunately, the backstory doesn't actually
match reality. A lot of those searches,
the vast majority actually started the day that
the 60 Minutes interview aired Sunday, which was
not a good interview for Donald Trump. But Trump
seemed to think that there was an explosion of
voters looking to change their votes from Biden
to Trump after voting. So Donald Trump tweeted,
quote, strongly trending Google since
immediately after the second debate
is, can I change my vote? This refers changing
it to me. The answer in most states is yes,
go do it. Most important election of your life.
Now, first of all, I don't think this is people
looking to change their votes already cast from
Biden to Trump. Again, the timing is not what
Trump says. It was not after the second debate.
It was overwhelmingly the 60 Minutes interview
that seems to have triggered people
to say, can I change my vote? Now,
you could you could venture a guess. Oh, it's
people wanting to change from Biden to Trump or
vice versa. As more and more people vote early. By
sheer math, you would imagine that more people are
going to be searching for that without necessarily
wanting to do it. But let let's put that aside.
It is not true that you simply can change your
vote. There are some states where you can,
but overwhelmingly you cannot. In Florida,
for example, where Donald Trump now votes,
if you cast your absentee ballot and it's
been received, processed and counted,
you can't change your vote. You just can't
do it. There are some states like Minnesota,
Michigan, Wisconsin, New York,
Pennsylvania, Mississippi, Connecticut,
they do allow alteration of votes after early
voting. That's six states. So, first of all,
Trump is against spreading voting disinformation
on Twitter. Secondly, and maybe most importantly,
it is not clear that this is people trying to
change their votes to Trump. It started trending
after Trump's ridiculous interview on 60 Minutes
where he walked out after getting reasonable,
real questions. And Trump looked terrible. Trump
thinks it's in his favor because The New York Post
published a story suggesting, you know, the
Biden's laptop. You know what? Whatever. Most
voters didn't see that story. That story is not
getting a lot of attention because it's ridiculous
and has nothing to do with Joe Biden. So this
is a very scared man who might get reelected.
He actually might get reelected. Whatever the
truth is about people wanting to change votes from
Biden to Trump, from Trump to Biden. Yes, Trump
is scared. Yes, Trump is desperate. But unless we
ensure he doesn't, he could get himself reelected.
He's on the ropes. He's trying anything he can.
Now he's on vote, changing after going from one
topic to another to another. The Trump ists are
pretending that this is not disturbing behavior,
but he is spreading more voting disinformation on
Twitter in the overwhelming number of states,
you can not change your vote. Trump is acting
like you can. And the really cynical. But
maybe maybe it's not overly it's cynical,
but it's not overly cynical. Maybe. There's this
idea that the reason Trump is doing this is he is
just trying to create chaos and tons of people
who try to change their votes who maybe will
come away on November 3rd believing their vote
counted for the wrong person because they tried.
But it wasn't clear. Did they change it that
they not the cynic would look at this and say,
this isn't just Trump wildly spreading
desperate disinformation on Twitter. This
is Trump specifically crafting stories that
voters will tell on November 3rd to justify
lawsuits to justify courts getting involved.
Sorry, I hit my microphone there to justify
any way possible to steal the election from
Joe Biden. That's what a cynic would say.
But I don't know that it's overly
cynical. Given what we've seen,